[Musique]
c'était il ya cinq ans jour pour jour le
13 novembre 2015 130 français
périssaient dans les terribles attentats
terroristes perpétrés à paris notamment
dans la salle de spectacle du bataclan
et dans différents restaurants de l'est
de la capitale au moment où je m'exprime
des attaques terroristes d'une ampleur
sans précédent sont en cours dans
l'agglomération parisienne
hier la veille de ce jour de mémoire
nationale plusieurs chaînes avaient
décidé d'aborder le sujet c'est le cas
par exemple de la chaîne tmc qui a
diffusé le documentaire fluctuat nec
mergitur qui est disponible depuis
plusieurs années sur des flics ce la
première pensée quant à sa fin sans race
et son gamin un documentaire qui retrace
ces terribles événements et qui met en
valeur les héros ordinaires qui se sont
révélés autour de ces drames des héros
un temps mise en avant mais très
rapidement oublier un an après les
événements il témoigné de
l'impossibilité de se reconstruire
c'est par exemple le cas de new look et
sidibé chef-adjoint de la sécurité du
bataclan qui a sauvé des dizaines de
personnes en les hissant une à une au
travers d'une petite trappe menant au
toit
il ne s'est jamais exprimée à la télé
depuis le lendemain des attaques new
look et sidibé était avec nous pour nous
parler de son histoire
et bien déjà merci d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup
ancien chef adjoint de la sécurité du
bataclan lors de la soirée du 13
novembre nous moquer vous étiez comme
tous les soirs depuis quinze ans au
bataclan pour faire simplement votre
travail
cinq ans après il est toujours
impossible pour vous d'oublier bien sur
ce qui s'est passé un grand mot soir
merci berland merci d'être là
aujourd'hui c'est bon c'est le 13
novembre
ça fait cinq ans que ça s'est passé est
ce que cette journée fin ce jour est
particulier pour vous oui c'est
particulier c'est particulier parce que
c était la terre est terrible la france
ait été attaquée le monde entier a été
attaqué la france ait été blessé mais a
mis toutes les personnes qui ont perdu
leurs proches
c'était une journée quand vous allez
vous je vais bien aujourd'hui c'est ni
combien de temps allait mieux deux en
deux ans oui deux en deux ans où il se
passer quoi vous étiez dans quel état
vous vous arriviez à dormir vous arrivez
à j'ai eu un peu de mal au départ parce
que ça a été terrible
est parti dans tous les sens vivre un
attentat je le souhaite à personne
moi je prône la paix j'ai une grosse
pensée et j'arrêterai pas de leur dire
pour toutes les victimes pour toutes les
familles et pour tous les agents de
sécurité qui étaient là souvent la
compagnie kenyane à un honneur bien sûr
forcément c'est très dur de 2,2 de se
mettre en avant
avec des événements comme ça mais ça a
été terrible la france n'est pas préparé
à ça personne n'est préparé un attentat
c'était assez compliqué parce que moi
j'avais justement mon père qui était
très malade qui est acquis je je je je
ce qui me soutenaient qui est mon mentor
qui est ma bibliothèque qui me qui m'a
toujours élevé donner une bonne
éducation mes frères et moi et c'était
très dur
et puis après j'ai dû me relever pour ma
mère mon père aimait mon entourage vous
fait qu'aujourd'hui je suis responsable
sûreté dans un groupe d'accord vous avez
retrouvé du travail a mis combien de
temps un pouvoir repartir vraiment deux
ans vraiment c'est écouter il fallait
que ma vie échange d'accords ouais c'est
ça du jour du jugement c était très dur
parce que ça faisait 20 ans que je
faisais de la sécurité et il faut savoir
que les concerts en général commence à
18h définissent à 23 minuit et derrière
j'enchaînais soit
en boîte de nuit soit dans les bras ce
loup je travaille un des points qui
s'étaient alors hier soir tmc diffusait
le documentaire 13 novembre fut tenu à
fluctuat nec mergitur très beau
documentaire qui a très bien marché les
ans que de 900 mille téléspectateurs et
dans ce documentaire des rescapés
reviennent avec émotion sur ce qu'il
ressentait au moment de la sauvergarde
c'était samedi c'est lui bon enfant
sympa la bonne musique tout le monde
s'éclate
ça aurait dû être ça c'est issam ce soir
[Applaudissements]
j'attends d'éclatement très sec quelque
chose de limites métallique en fait dans
qui qui qui va venir sans des
l'atmosphère du bateau classé des
espèces de bruit très sourd claquant
panpan vraiment des what you say to
prennent aux tripes et je suis j'ai
demandé à nicomaque qu'est ce qui se
passe il sans vouloir y croire je sais
ce qu'ils je sais ce que c'est mais je
veux pas je veux pas le reconnaître
alors c'est vrai que c'est à chaque fois
qu'on voit ces images on est on est tous
meurtris on est tous classés alors j'ai
plein de questions à vous poser pour
cette dernière partie
tpm puisqu'il faut que je n'en sois là à
20h51
c'est parti
[Musique]
et on est dans le 20 minutes médias est
vraiment merci d'être avec nous nos
moquer je me sens toujours très très
atteints non pas du tout vraiment non si
ma posture vraiment vous êtes venu juste
ah oui toujours
c'est quoi alors sur le moment est ce
que vous avez tout de suite compris que
c'était une attaque terroriste
oui heureusement vous étiez vous quand
parce que vous étiez 15 personnes donc
de la sécurité on était sept 7 d'accord
parce qu'elle a 15 quand même au
bataclan normalement où il sera là vous
étiez 7
oui on sait que je parle mais vous
n'étiez pas armés bien entendu sur voile
à bord mais comment ça s'est passé vous
y avez dit dit mon ami qui était à
nantes réduit et moi j'étais j'étais un
petit peu en retrait de lui et puis il y
avait le carré fumeurs à l'extérieur
et puis d'un seul coup d'un seul coup
c'est parti là bas et que vous aviez un
moment on va tous sauté ah oui mouais 6
à un moment je me suis retrouvé dans les
escaliers parce que quand je suis rentré
dans le bataclan moi j'ai été tout de
suite sur la file de droite lui mon ami
et colony a foncé dans la fosse donc lui
a vraiment fait un acte héroïque au
niveau des portes de secours qui a plus
beaucoup de personnes et moi j'ai pris
j'ai pris licite de j'ai pris tout de
suite à droite en attendant le bataclan
et puis c'était terrible je mets un
moment je me suis retournée et sa satire
elle pas tous les sens c'était terrible
si tu es une zone de guerre et ce moment
là il est au niveau de la de la pression
pourrais pas vous dire qu'est ce qu'on
ressent
c'est vraiment je ne le souhaite à
personne
et dieu seul sait que j'ai ça fait
longtemps que je faisais de la sécurité
que j'ai bossé dans des milieux ont été
parfois très dure mais là c'était
vraiment si je peux me le permettre et
j'aime pas dire ce moment là c'était
vraiment en gt1 alors vous dit quelque
chose
je ne voulais pas me comporter comme un
lâche vous avez un moment vous ai dit je
peux peut-être mon fuir mais vous n'avez
pas voulu faire n'ont jamais vous dire
ce que un moment n'était dans un
escalier pendant pendant plus d'une
heure et demie il y avait des gens en
train de pleurer déjà en train de crier
ça criait partout ça criait partout
c'était désastreux et moi
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un régisseur qui
a ouvert ici de secours du toit on a
plus on a pu monter et fait remonter
aussi les gens avec et puisse s'y
retrouver dans les meubles dans un
appartement juste au dessus sur le toit
du bataclan au fait qu'ils donnaient
exactement dans le bar et puis un moment
c'est vrai qu'il allait être ouverte
et puis là je pense à ma fille je pense
à mes parents je vraiment a dit je vais
essayer de sauver ma peau
ça te passe par la tête mais après tu ne
peux pas parce que les gens sont en
train de pleurer il ya des femmes il ya
des gens et puis je ne peux pas
abandonner les gens même en tout le
monde est en détresse ça veut dire que
c'est c'est même plus la sécurité ça
dépasse la sécurité puisque les agents
de sécurité ne sont pas formés et ne
sont pas préparés à sarkissian et on l'a
vu tout au long de plein de reportages à
la télé ou même certains policiers
on était tous des passes et c'était là
la france entière qui a été dépassé donc
si c'est l'humain si il ya des gens dans
cette salle ce soir la con con con con
con con tout perdu quand tout perdu ça a
été dur de se construire un moment mais
moi j'avais mes proches et dieu seul
sait qu'ils sont importants pour moi et
qui m'ont permet tout de suite de 2-2-2
d'aller de l'avant
et puis le lendemain on se pose plein de
questions ça fait quinze ans que tu fais
ce boulot là j'ai dit que vous êtes vous
êtes posé la question avant d'arrêter la
sécurité ou bien sûr oui bien sûr bien
sûr vous êtes vous êtes des quoi c'est
simple c'est plus pour moi j'ai pris à
lui parce que j'avais déjà j'avais déjà
survécu à lui a à l'époque pas quelque
chose de similaire mais à quelque chose
de qui avait été aussi très très chaud
pendant le milieu de la nuit et je me
suis dit à un moment bon voilà il faut
que t'arrêtes il faut que tu tu passe au
dessus
j'ai vu toutes mes années défiler j'ai
surmonté même eu au mercredi soir
l'avant-veille du bataclan où c'était un
concert hip hop c'était un artiste qui
s'appelait john toll qui étaient là et
je me rappelle il y avait plein
d'artistes que je connaissais donc on
était tous devant la porte parce qu'en
général le bataillon c'est tellement un
endroit qui coule en général c'est ça la
série que ban devant la porte ça il y
avait c'était un petit peu on se serait
immiscé on y voit la ccic il ya plein
d'agents de sécurité à travailler ce
soir là mais quelle institution vu dans
le bataclan c'est ça ils ont été
extraordinaires la plupart de nos
téléphones sonnaient c'était c'était
terrible alors c'est vrai que vous êtes
retourne au bataclan depuis oui mais
bien sûr avec des jeux avec des j étais
devant avec des jeunes de ma ville pour
leur montrer un petit peu ce qui s'était
passé quand vous êtes retourné vous avez
revu les images et l'image bien sûr oui
bien sûr et puis après je j'ai regardé
le j'avais dit à mon grand frère qui
m'avait appelé j'avais dit à mon grand
frère qui pour qui j'ai un énorme
respect éthique et qui est mon exemple
je lui avais dit reste là je vais
revenir et lui était chez moi il n'est
pas bougé de de toute la nuit et quand
je suis rentré chez moi je lui dis mais
qu'est ce que tu fais là
et puis là je vais je suis un peu
expliqué et en fait voilà ça a été ça a
été un moment difficile surtout le
lendemain et pendant et pendant deux
trois jours la semaine il estime qu ont
suivi tu te dis un moment qu'est ce que
je veux faire
qu'est ce que je vais devenir et c'est
là que tu te rends compte que la famille
est importante donc est en tout cas
merci d'être venu nous voir être venu
témoigner ce soir est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez vous êtes retourné dans la
sécurité
bien sûr vous êtes heureux quand même
d'être venu oui mais voilà ce que j'ai
j'ai un super patron serait pour un
super groupe
ils m'ont donné ma réussi à raccrocher
non ils m'ont tendu la main il m'a tendu
la main et c'était un projet cohérent et
ça me permettait de passer à une autre
étape de ma vie
justement c'est pour ça que j'ai et puis
quand ça fait 20 ans qu'on fait un
métier
et puis j'arrive porte des jets avec m
37 38 ans à l'époque je sais faire pas
mal de choses mais la sécu c'est un
métier que j'aime mais ça me surtout un
métier que je sais faire
vous avez sauvé énormément de vie je
préfère mes bons amis
est-ce que vous avez revu des gens oui
bien sûr c'est vrai des gens que vous
avez sauvé oudéa sur des appels
téléphoniques et puis un moment j'ai
j'ai préféré stopper
ah oui là vous voyez plus personne parce
que parce que parce qu'à un moment il
faut que chacun fasse son deuil et que
malheureusement et heureusement il faut
avancer nous moquer sidibé était avec
nous ce soir c'était notre témoin soit
merci pour votre témoignage est vraiment
bravo encore pour vraiment s'il vole à
votre attitude est ce que vous avez fait
merci new look et si libé merci beaucoup
vraiment si important qu'on parle de ça
ce soir et qui n'est votre témoignage